fruchtbonbons mit obst blumen oder
tiermotive handgefertigt von einem
deutschen bonbon macher in polen
florian welle gasgeschäft befindet sich
in der danziger altstadt
hier kann seine kundschaft verfolgen wie
aus einer farblosen zuckermasse bunte
bonbons entstehen
vor acht jahren zog der friseur der
liebe wegen von köln nach danzig und
machte seine passion für süß ist zu
seinem neuen beruf wie die kinder dabei
eine 160 grad celsius heiße zuckermasse
ist die basis mehrere schichten werden
ineinander gewickelt und nach und nach
entsteht ein riesen bonbon eine stunde
dauert es um rund zehn kilogramm bonbons
mit fruchtgeschmack herzustellen harte
arbeit
acht kilo sr zähflüssiger zuckermasse
fliegen hier durch die luft
diese eingezogene luft verändert den
zucker in dreierlei hinsicht a der
zucker wird weiß sieht man liegt daran
dass sich das licht an dass durch die
zuckermasse dich dann den zweiten effekt
haben dass strecken besser schmeckt süß
ist in verschiedenen geschmacksvarianten
und farb motiven
das war für kinder wie erwachsene mit
seiner bonbon manufaktur ist florian
belgrad mittlerweile so erfolgreich dass
er bereits sein viertes geschäft in
polen eröffnet hat das konzept kostprobe
und show geht auf
motive und buchstaben zu formen und
ganze worte in ein einzelnes bonbon
hineinzuschreiben das ist die hohe kunst
hier entsteht gerade ein jeder einzelne
große zucker streifen entspricht einem
buch starb
ich bin gelernter natürlich auch gerne
irgendein ergebnis soll deswegen so ist
schöner wenn ich mit maschinen arbeitet
natürlich auch die bank mache die mit
maschinen arbeiten wird mit maschinen
gearbeitet drückt man auf den knopf
bekommt am ende das fertige buch raus
bei uns ist immer so ein bisschen
überraschend dadurch dass für die halt
von hand machen war ich bin halt nie hat
man jetzt in buchstaben vertauscht
seht ihr erdbeere so aus wie sie
aussehen soll oder muss man sie im
anschluss himbeere verkaufen
die technik stammt aus dem 17
jahrhundert seit 2012 bietet florian
belgrad auch deutschland bonbons an
wir sind der letzten fußball
europameisterschaft waren sie der renner
und verkaufen sich auch jetzt noch gut
bei deutschen touristen die danzig
besuchen
mit 160 grad temperatur an
aber da wo ich jetzt durchbrechen
schwarz-rot-gold german richtig
täglich werden hier bonbons in allen
möglichen farb- und geschmacksvarianten
produziert der fantasie sind keine
grenzen gesetzt
wer möchte kann sogar sein eigenes
bonbon entwerfen und es von florian
bellgardt umsetzen lassen ein ganz
persönliches souvenir aus danzig